Welcome to the Sequencer Event Structures for Game Development
course for Unreal Engine 5.5.
This course is the second video in this series designed
to provide you Sequencer-based workflows,
specifically in building in-game cutscenes for video games.
We'll recap game development principles, Sequencer concepts,
features, and tools, then dive into creating Blueprint logic
to control our in-game cutscenes, script player inputs,
and lastly, trigger an event through an external actor.
We'll also include some best practice recommendations
when using Sequencer for game development.
For this course, you'll find the Sequence 205 Start Map located
in your Content Browser under Courses, Sequence 205 Maps.